[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las historias de nuestro continente
argentina está a un paso de legalizar el
aborto la cámara de diputados aprobó el
proyecto de ley que permite interrumpir
el embarazo por decisión de la madre en
un país en el que se registraron hasta
500 mil abortos clandestinos en un año
pero antes de entrar en vigor la
iniciativa debe recibir luz verde del
senado donde se estancó en 2018 y méxico
sería el primer país de américa latina
en comenzar a vacunar a su población
contra el kobe 19 el gobierno de andrés
manuel lópez obrador anunció que
comenzará a aplicar la inyección de
facer y bayonne tec al personal médico
en la primera línea de batalla contra el
coronavirus la tercera semana de
diciembre
y la nominación del presidente electo
joe biden como secretario de defensa
llevaría por primera vez en la historia
a un afroamericano a liderar el
pentágono pero hay controversia
alrededor del recientemente general
retirado lloyd austin les contamos por
qué
y vamos de inmediato con nuestra
historia principal la cámara de
diputados de argentina aprobó la
legalización de la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo hasta la semana
14 solo por decisión de la madre es
decir no sólo en casos de violación o
riesgo para su vida como se permitía
hasta ahora antes de ser legal el
proyecto debe recibir el visto bueno del
senado donde fue rechazado hace dos años
el debate sobre la legalización del
aborto impacta a toda la sociedad pero
sobre todo se vuelve relevante para
aquellas mujeres que se tuvieron que
someter a un aborto clandestino nos lo
cuenta nuestro corresponsal en buenos
aires- natalio kosor
hace 30 años cecilia maras y decidió
abortar cuando mente era usted
embarazada no tuve ningún tipo de duda
como la duda el embarazo había sido
resultado de una violación y como ocurre
en muchos casos por una mezcla de
desconocimiento y el estigma que
acompaña al aborto recurrió a la
clandestinidad de una camilla en el
medio de un montón de libros todos
sucios
las preguntas antes de que la anestesia
tome efecto era
tremendas
me asustaron más que el aborto de sí
dónde estás alguien te vio nos recuerda
en la dirección
no cuentes a nadie que a cada quien te
está esperando abajo y al día siguiente
me tuve que ir a inaugurar me desmayé me
salí me caí del colectivo pues no podía
revisar que vivir por eso con una
hemorragia tremenda
bolt historias como estas que cientos de
mujeres salieron a celebrar frente al
congreso el día en que el presidente
alberto fernández envió al legislativo
un proyecto para legalizar el aborto y
evitar la clandestinidad una
clandestinidad que implica demás cargas
legales y sociales aun cuando haya pocas
condenas firmes por aborto efectivamente
lo que hay son pocas condenas lo que no
significa que no haya todo un aparato y
todo un sistema puesto a perseguir
mujeres por hechos de aborto es todo un
sistema que se extiende también en
muchos casos al contexto más cercano de
la persona que decide abortar no me
arrepiento
pero esta gente muy llegada a mis amigos
me han dicho dios te va a castigar vas a
quedar estéril tus hijas van a nacer mal
si tus hijos van a nacer mal
a los 24 años tuve a mi primer hija
estoy asustada hasta el momento que era
vi
para que mujeres como sus hijas no deban
pasar por lo mismo que pasó a ella
cecilia también lleva el pañuelo verde
que usan quienes quieren que cambie la
ley
y después de que el reino unido se
convirtiera en el primer país del mundo
en vacunar contra el kobe 19 a sus
ciudadanos canadá y eeuu se aceleraron a
aprobar el uso de emergencia de la
vacuna de facer y bayonne tec para
comenzar a aplicarla antes de que
termine el 2020 mientras tanto los 630
millones de habitantes de américa latina
nos preguntamos cuándo llegará la vacuna
a nuestros países y es que con un vasto
territorio y zonas impenetrables no sólo
el acceso representa un desafío sino
también la conservación de la inyección
que debe permanecer a bajas temperaturas
algunos países han apostado por hacer
compras a diferentes laboratorios pero
la mayoría tiene sus esperanzas puestas
en el kóvacs un plan impulsado por la
organización mundial de la salud para
según dice garantizar un acceso justo y
equitativo a la vacuna
veamos en qué va la vacunación en
américa latina' el gobierno de méxico
anunció que empezaría a vacunar al
personal médico a partir de la tercera
semana de diciembre colombia dijo que no
empezará hasta el primer trimestre de
2021 mientras que venezuela señaló que
empezaría en diciembre de 2020 pero con
las vacunas producidas por rusia y
china- que no tienen pruebas de
efectividad
brasil también utilizará esa
específicamente en el estado de sao
paulo a partir de enero de 2021
argentina comenzaría a utilizar la
vacuna rusa a finales de 2020 y chile
que ha hecho acuerdo con varios
laboratorios empezará en el primer
trimestre de 2021
en ese orden de ideas méxico se
convertiría en el primer país de américa
latina en iniciar un plan de vacunación
masiva con la inyección de facer y bayón
tech
méxico se convertirá en el primer país
de américa latina en vacunar a sus
ciudadanos contra el kobe 19 el gobierno
mexicano y facer llegaron a un acuerdo
para la distribución de 34,4 millones de
dosis de la inyección que produce la
farmacéutica junto a diane tec a partir
de diciembre si todo marcha como se ha
planteado y como le hemos venido
platicando con fai ser tanto en el
ámbito de lo regulatorio como en el
ámbito operativo del programa nacional
de vacunación tendremos las vacunas en
la penúltimo los últimos días de la
tercera semana de diciembre y en cuanto
llegue empezará a utilizarse
la vacuna se distribuirá en el país
norteamericano en cuatro etapas la
primera de diciembre de 2020 a febrero
de 2021 se aplicarán 250.000 vacunas
para el personal de salud en la primera
línea de batalla contra el cob y 19
desde abril de 2021 hasta mayo serán
vacunados los mexicanos entre 50 y 59
años al siguiente mes los ciudadanos
entre 40 y 49 años y de julio en
adelante el resto de la población
estamos
[Música]
pensando que se va a contar
con todas las dosis y que lo vamos a
lograr este año que viene y que todos
estemos vacunados méxico es el país con
la mayor tasa de mortalidad en el
planeta con el 93 por ciento según la
universidad johns hopkins
y méxico es el país de la región más
peligroso para ejercer el periodismo
según reporteros sin fronteras
regina martínez era una periodista que
investigaba los vínculos entre los
cárteles del narcotráfico y las
autoridades fue asesinada hace 8 años
pero este año un grupo de periodistas
investigativos retomó la historia en la
que estaba trabajando antes de morir y
esto fue lo que encontró
[Música]
quien quería silenciar a esta periodista
conocida como la chaparrita
qué descubrió durante su investigación
de más de una década sobre los
gobernadores del estado de veracruz y
sus presuntos vínculos con los
narcotraficantes
fue varias veces amenazada por sus
informes hasta su muerte en abril de
2012 cuando fue brutalmente golpeada en
su casa
regina trabajaba para procesos
reconocido semanario mexicano sus
colegas decidieron investigar su
asesinato pero no llegaron muy lejos
para recibir una amenaza de muerte
naturalmente el efecto fue devastador y
decidimos separarnos de la investigación
un grupo de 60 periodistas
internacionales retomo lo que los
colegas de regina tuvieron que detener y
tras una investigación de 10 meses están
reconstruyendo el reporte que ella no
tuvo tiempo de publicar
antes de morir regina estaba rastreando
a cientos de personas que desaparecieron
como conductores de taxi chicas
acompañantes y empresarios personas que
fueron testigos de cosas que los
cárteles de drogas no querían que fueran
vistas regina descubrió que esos
mexicanos habían sido secuestrados y
enterrados en fosas comunes y que las
autoridades fueron cómplices
esa zona en donde no ha sido protegida
no solamente por los criminales sino
también por autoridades y en este caso
me refiero a policías municipales
policías ministeriales claros y regina
hubiera publicado esa información lo
hubiera sido
una bomba para el gobierno solo las
grabaciones de las últimas entrevistas
hechas por regina y su computador fueron
robadas la noche de su muerte las
autoridades lo registraron como un
asalto común que se salió de control y
presentaron a un sospechoso quien
defiende su inocencia un fiscal federal
fue apuntado al caso pero la
investigación fue entorpecida las
autoridades locales siempre estuvieron
ocultando información desplazando la
información a lo mejor no vamos a saber
quién mató a regina pero si sé a quién
no mató a regina toma al ser interrogado
sobre el asesinato de la periodista el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
prometió reabrir la investigación desde
la muerte de regina martínez 52
periodistas han muerto en méxico por el
simple hecho de ser periodistas
el presidente electo de eeuu joe biden
sigue revelando los nombres de su
gabinete esta semana denominó al general
retirado lloyd austin si es confirmado
en el cargo sería el primer
afroamericano en dirigir el pentágono
pero hay un punto de debate la
constitución dice que el secretario de
defensa debe ser un civil o haber estado
por fuera de las fuerzas armadas durante
al menos siete años y este no es el caso
de austin
una elección con el potencial de hacer
historia el presidente electo joe biden
nomino al general lloyd austin como su
secretario de defensa de ser confirmado
por el senado
austin sería el primer afroamericano en
dirigir el pentágono pero puede
enfrentar oposición de algunos miembros
del congreso que prefieren un liderazgo
civil que militar
austin se retiró del ejército como un
general de cuatro estrellas en 2016
después de prestar servicio durante 41
años ascendió hasta convertirse en el
jefe del comando central de eeuu donde
era el responsable de supervisar la
estrategia militar en medio oriente
es respetado y conocido por ser un
fuerte comandante de batalla pero su
confirmación necesita que los
legisladores cedan pues la ley establece
un mínimo de siete años entre prestar
servicio y dirigir el pentã gono y
austin se retiró hace apenas cuatro esta
sería la tercera vez en la historia en
la que un presidente solicita una
excepción desde que la ley de seguridad
nacional fue aprobada en 1947 el primero
en hacerlo fue harry truman cuando
nomino a george marshall en 1950 más
recientemente el presidente donald trump
pidió una para nominar al general james
mattis el congreso estima que sólo
circunstancias especiales deben permitir
tener a un militar retirado en el
departamento de defensa no es claro si
hay suficientes legisladores dispuestos
a apoyar la excepción necesaria tras la
nominación de mattis en 2016 algunos
congresistas han dicho que fue un error
haber apoyado en la excepción y han
indicado que no lo harán nuevamente
y me despido con el tráiler de la nueva
película de disney encanto
no no
[Música]
una película animada que contará la
historia de una familia colombiana una
de las escenas que más llama la atención
es una en la que aparecen unas mariposas
amarillas
seguramente inspiradas en las descritas
por gabriel garcía márquez en la obra
que le valió el premio nobel de
literatura- 100 años de soledad
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa pueden seguirme en redes
sociales en la dirección que ven en sus
pantallas sigan viendo france24
[Música]